foreign
Michael is in Seattle hey Michael how
are you
okay I'm good Dave how are you better
than I deserve what's up
yeah so
um I've done the right things uh my
whole life financially I actually
discovered you guys once I was on a
really formidable path and kind of in a
good place but being that a lot of the
the Ramsay values aligned with how I
already felt I started kind of watching
some YouTube videos whatever it's always
good to find other people that are right
I like confirmation bias as well
but uh so like long story short I'm in a
position now where I I you know all the
big purchases are done and settled down
and I kind of want to treat myself to a
second car a sports car and it just
feels
um a little wasteful just for the fact
that I know that I could do better
things uh with my money like just even
leave it in you know an online savings
account right now at four and a half
percent and you know that's still
ticking up right so it just feels a
little wasteful trying to figure out
what's the cost all the time
uh the car would be like 80 after it's
all said and done what's your net worth
uh about 1.35 okay what's your income
uh last year it was about 440. okay get
the car
get the cart treat yourself
that's kind of how I feel yes come on
now
okay let me tell you what let me tell
you the thing that Sharon and I do okay
okay because it was hard for us
to after for so many years being Frugal
for so many years it was hard for us to
make the transition to enjoy money
okay yeah and there's two things that
have enabled us to do some things that
feel in in air quotes wasteful uh but
really what that means is I'm enjoying
some money uh I've lived like no one
else so now I can live and give like no
one else there's two things that do that
number one I look at my generosity
and uh if I were buying an 80 000 car I
know that in addition to our tithe to
our local church we give
way more than that
so if I were buying an 80 000 car my
generosity to wonderful Ministries and
to help the poor and to help whoever in
different ways whatever struggling group
it is that we're trying to help
um is way in excess of our enjoyment
okay so that's one thing in other words
am I am I spending more on me than I am
on others
okay that's one that's one thing that
gives me peace about it and I'm not okay
the second thing that gives me peace
about it and this is probably even more
important is I call it the uh burn it in
the middle of the floor test
if you put eighty thousand dollars in
the middle of the floor and you set fire
to it
would your life change
no no
yeah so it passes the burn it in the
middle of the floor test
if you put 800 000 in the middle of
floor and burned it you would oh yeah
that your life would change yeah so you
can't do that so there isn't right you
know that that that's where we are or if
you have a hundred thousand dollars to
your name and you're gonna take eighty
thousand dollars and burn it well it
changes your life right
yeah so you don't pass that you don't
burn the past the burning in the middle
of the floor test and I never really
named it I never really gave it a name
until just now but that's I like that
that's there that's that I just named
the test today but um but the point is
am I doing something that tells me on I
always look at ratios and the ratio of
this car to your net worth and your
income is small enough that Jade without
thinking said right and so and that's
that past the past the the ratio is so
small that you're not doing something
dumb yeah when you reach a point that it
is impacting your life for a luxury item
or your lug or your generosity is
smaller than your luxury item then that
doesn't pass the test yeah so you have
earned the right you need to do this and
as long as our ratios are there and we
do this uh uh um uh Michael in addition
we do this with our income because you
make a fabulous income so this is a a
formula we use uh I just got one of my
uh Total Money Makeover royalty checks
this week okay I get them I get them
like four times a year I get them
quarterly and uh so that's like mailbox
money right so any money like that above
what we need to live I just take that
and I apply a formula to it uh number
one the government gets 40 number two uh
my tie this ten percent so that's fifty
that that's 50 of it's gone the other 50
I split among three categories enjoyment
additional generosity beyond the tithe
and investment additional investment and
so that check is already spent
there's a percentage that's going to go
to enjoyment without guilt
because I'm doing the additional
generosity and because I'm being
responsible with the investing and oh
I'm paying my taxes there's that but
yeah but you see what I'm doing so the
that same formula or that same
philosophy is applied in that formula do
you feel it
yeah absolutely and I mean I I think you
know the transition to learning how to
enjoy is tough for people who have been
Frugal
it's a new muscle positive Association
yeah you get such a positive association
with always saving money but anytime you
go to spend it feels really weird and
kind of foreign
that's a normal malady of somebody
that's got two million dollars it's the
first thing and you know the first time
I moved from a junk car after bankruptcy
into a decent car I went through this
like this is so dumb because these
things go down in value this is so
irresponsible
and I was buying a five-year-old Jaguar
it wasn't like I was buying some super
expensive car at the time but my
emotions were just you know fingernails
down a chalkboard because I'm not going
I'm not going to be broke again I'm not
going to be stupid again I'm not going
to go back there all this stuff in your
head you know and so uh but yeah that
that's kind of when I had to get okay if
I turn this car up
in my area yeah it doesn't matter oh so
I'm not spending that much really okay I
can afford to do that I can afford this
upgrade and you can do that with a lot
of things
um and it'll keep you from doing too
much luxury stuff but um
that's so good I I also think it's
better money spent that we don't do a
ton of extravagant travel and I mean a
trip is lighted on fire once it's gone
it's gone you're no longer in the
destination you no longer have the money
and so I always felt like the car too
although it you know depreciates but if
you take good care of it and don't drive
it a whole ton if you know if your goals
and aspirations or your desires change
in a few years you can probably get out
of it with you know not too too much
damage but you won't even need to get
out of it yeah I got a 1960 Corvette
because I was being born a 1960 frame up
restoration it was and I drive it about
eight times a year I promise you if I
told my wife we're doing that instead of
a trip I would not own that car
civilization won't work at Ramsey house
I'm just saying because Sharon Sharon's
bags are packed to go on a trip I'm just
all the time so yeah but both both fall
in the enjoyment category both are okay
yeah but they're a small percentage of
your world that's right that's where you
keep it and then you don't have any
reason to feel guilty and that helps you
to hit the enjoyment button buy the car
we didn't even ask it what it was it
doesn't matter oh
Porsche 911 was it he told he told the
phone screener oh definitely get that
car